if you want to know how people like
Dwayne Johnson Jeff Bezos
and Bill Gates study the game and keep
learning then this video is for you know
your business become a student of the
game you have to learn learn learn learn
learn I love being a student
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that potential that
thing inside you burst out into the
world and have a huge impact I started
the one rule series to try to look at
all the top 10 videos that I've been
putting together and try to see what are
the common patterns the common rules
that keep coming up over and over and
over again so today we're gonna learn
how to study the game enjoy
[Music]
when I was at the height of my career in
the WWE I felt that for the very first
time that I was close to accomplishing
everything that I wanted to accomplish
in wrestling and I quietly walked away
kind of shook me a little bit because
wrestling was all I knew at that time
and I had dabbled in acting but yet I
also felt that I wanted to do more and I
wanted to achieve more and I wanted to
grow I wanted to grow as a person I
wanted to grow as an entertainer and
that I wanted to reach as many people as
possible not for the box-office value of
it but before the connection and I had
come from a world where I was connecting
with an audience every night and I
wanted that connection and I wanted to
not only be good as an actor but if I
made the transition into acting I wanted
to be great I knew going in the cards
are stacked against me there's a shelf
life to a career if I just wanted to get
by on popularity I didn't want to be in
that position I wanted longevity if
that's the goal then I have to do
everything I could possibly do to know
the business of Hollywood from top to
bottom from acting to marketing to an
executive level to a producing level to
a directing level and just know it as a
whole that would inherently make me a
greater asset and I appreciate all the
people in the beginning of my career as
I was coming up who took the time who
took the effort who took me in because I
had to educate myself and I had to be
student of the game know your business
know your business and become a student
of the game and surround yourself with
brilliant people
go to work if you want to be an inventor
of any kind inventing a new you know a
new service offering for customers or a
new product or anything the being an
inventor requires because the world is
so complicated you have to be a domain
expert I mean in a way even if even if
you're not the beginning you have to
learn learn learn learn learn enough so
to become a domain expert but the danger
is once you've become a domain expert
you can be trapped by that knowledge and
so inventors have this paradoxical
ability to have that you know 10,000
hours of practice and be a real domain
expert and have that beginner's mind
have that that look at it freshly even
though they know so much about the
domain and that's the key to inventing
you have to have both and I think that
is intentional I think all of us have
that inside of us and we could all do it
but you have to be intentional about it
you have to say yeah I am gonna become
an expert and I'm gonna keep my
beginner's mind you went to Harvard and
you're dropped out have you ever thought
how your life could be better off if you
had gotten your Harvard degree well I
I'm a weird dropout because I take
college courses all the time I love
learning company courses and things so I
love being a student and there were
smart people around and you know they
fed you and they gave you these nice
grades that made you feel smart so I
feel it was unfortunate that I didn't
get to stay there but I don't think I
missed any knowledge because you know
whatever I needed to learn I would I was
still in a learning mode and you gotta
have that ability it's the kind of
self-criticism you know what I mean and
and learning and being willing to you
know take a step back and you know learn
more and not just feel like I mean a lot
of times you know it's so many artists I
just feel like now on the hottest why am
I not you know I mean why am I not doing
arenas right now why why am I not here
how did my mixtape get slept on how did
I you know I mean whatever but you
really just got a it's all about just
paying dues and just taking that time
and just putting the work in keep
learning when you cease to learn you
cease to grow when you cease to learn
you sort of begin to decay a little bit
you are to learn to how to stay healthy
and you say well how do I do that well
the proper diet and exercise and rest
that's part of it in other words we're
not healthy by accident it's by learning
some key things in life that really make
a difference and when we keep learning
something happens in our life for
example you're not living in an age when
we've had to keep learning because when
I was born there were no computers that
I knew of
in 1900 and 32 so we go back and you
look at your life and think about all
the things that you've had to learn that
your predecessors and your church your
parents didn't have to learn because
they didn't even exist so if you if
you're gonna be useful all the days of
your life you've got to be willing to
keep learning so I would simply say that
a lazy brain is an aging brain you don't
want to learn what happens you start
decaying and so there's something
interesting and exciting about learning
things in life no matter who you are and
no matter what your age you might be if
you're really going to get ahead you
have to study your craft you have to
deeply study it you know I I decided
what was it now 18 years ago that I
wanted to help inspire and motivate
people and I wanted to coach people one
on one on motivation on high performance
and I wanted to write books on the
topics so 18 years ago I started reading
a book a week on psychology leadership
communication marketing and there get on
my hand about human behavior and
performance I was studying everything I
could in a psychology every single week
now it's like people like wait you've
read a book a week for 17 years I don't
brag about I'm not like oh yeah look at
me that was for my passion I knew if I
really wanted to succeed at something I
had to study it and I had to study it
deeply and I couldn't you know spend all
this time doing a lot of things so I had
to study my craft the great artists of
our past history that's what they did
they didn't one didn't they had a true
level of depth of study in that area now
maybe they dabbled in some other areas
too but they became famous because they
study in one area and so what's your
area what's what's the thing you need to
study on develop a deep level of
competence into how to do it and how
that world works because you know we
have a saying in Montana that the time
to have the map is before you enter the
woods but a lot of people have a dream
and they run out into the woods and they
just start trying stuff and they take
this path and this path and this path
and this path and because they didn't
study best practices they sundae with
one don't you know that they wake up and
they're lost they're confused about who
they are and where they're at and
they're in this dark forest of the
unknown with no plan to get out they had
no idea they just jumped into something
they didn't study before taking that
leap and I would say you know what study
pay attention learn from the best model
the most intelligent smart successful
people you can in any given area that
you want to succeed in in your life
before you get into it then develop
competency by doing it over and over and
over and over again don't do it once in
awhile here and there over and over and
over that's how you get competence found
and I had an idea took it to the
marketplace learned how to pitch it
change my environment started hanging
around winners where the winners don't
top the hill bro get to the bottom of
the hill they're not the Holiday Inn the
Marriott ok they're not where my momma
told me to go my mama taught me save
everything save everything save
everything and she taught me that for
one reason because she didn't know how
to make money so what I've done but I'm
58 years old just turned 59 actually
i'ma spend the rest of my life helping
people figure out what I did okay
everybody should have everybody should
build and do this everybody should have
the opportunity to take their families
their kids their wife your husband take
them wherever they want to go okay
everybody shoot this everybody does have
a potato
most people just are not willing to read
study learn so now if you are one of
those people here's a little warning to
you gotta pick your benches carefully I
tell captain Ryan all the time I like
captain Ryan you just can't you can't
listen to everybody you can't study
everybody those of you out there there
study and you're like you're opening up
every Facebook feed every snapchat
looking at every YouTube video you have
to pick pick
you got a pick
see is he good people right you got a
pic who you gonna laughing okay you got
a pic who you're gonna learn from you
you have to be selective if I'm if I'm
somebody did you resonate with study me
okay if I'm not if I'm not forgot then
find somebody this bayed it okay not
just money but has time for their family
time for vacations time for spirituality
time to take care of the physical
condition time to give back time for
charity time to help the military out
those guys are out there serving over
there look find somebody that matches
your values and study that person deep
if you could talk to your younger self
knowing what you know in those days when
you thought maybe it's not gonna happen
what would you tell yourself pretty cool
I'd say
I'd said play the cool and learn as much
as you can because everything you learn
you're gonna need you won't have enough
time to learn everything is in education
as a rapper there's very few greats that
I studied and I still continue to study
and knowledge is obviously one of them
is obvious
I really had his lyrics printed on my
wall they just had a site was called Ola
original hip-hop lyrics whatever dot-com
or archive yeah somebody know and then
you you print them out so I would print
these joints out and I would I would
print them up and hang them up on my
wall and literally if you walk in my
room you might be I was wrong this kid
I'm staring at like this just reading
the lyrics because I wanted to know what
it was like to be that good you know to
me like and I was rapping at the time so
I wanted to know and it was my goal to
be that good I wanted to somehow try to
master the style I felt like if I read
it enough if I listen I used to go to
sleep listening in to I am you know to
me and people be sleeping on that I
might be trying to tell them and man is
spitting on for real on that album I
used to go to sleepless in that album
because I wanted to try to master the
style if I could you know I mean you
can't master that style but I felt about
you how you probably felt about rock
camera okay Naji rapper whoever it was
that you looked at like the god that's
how I felt and then the last point and
this is one of my favorites and this is
one that people really miss out on is
study success successful people study
success success is not what we naively
think is just something that happens
naturally to some people and doesn't
happen other people success is a very
deliberate conscious endeavor that you
undertake success is built over months
and years and it's done consciously and
the more you understand the principles
of success the concepts of success the
more you study people who have been
successful the more you see what it
really takes and that process of success
the principles are not always what they
seem and to me this is something that I
really committed my life to is studying
these principles I really love it
it's exciting for me and I really
encourage you to get involved with that
so that means maybe attendings
seminars reading some books watching
these videos learning about it maybe
joining a group of friends that are
successful joining a mastermind group
right be around successful people learn
how the success process works and learn
the psychology of success not the
externals of success but the psychology
that's what we're talking about thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what was the
favorite clip that you had in this video
who said something that's really
resonated with you that you're going to
apply somehow to your life your business
I would love to know please leave it
down in the comments below I also want
to give a quick charter to the Josh
speaks thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
doing a youtube review on it and posting
it to Twitter I really appreciate the
support man and I'm so glad you enjoyed
the book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple epic or its core value is
that that people passion and not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details